on coasts and beaches across the world
predator and prey clash in Savage
battles of survival
but what happens when these ruthless
killings turn against each other
despite tooth and Claw against their own
kid to win food territory and rights to
the bloodline
in the wild there are no rules
this is Animal Fight Night
[Music]
to survive on the cold coasts of the
Arctic
we've got to be tough
and if you want to fight here
you've got to be even tougher
the polar bear
the largest predator on dry land
prices have as heavy the grizzly they're
built like no other
[Music]
Maps capable of lifting 200 pounds with
eagles
they'll take down anything that crosses
their path including
each other
and when there's a girl involved the
stakes are high
they go head to head in a game of last
Bear's standard
fights are short but injuries are heavy
their sheer power can break bones with
ease
gaping wounds can end the Bear's mating
season
and often it's life
early summer
this teenage bear has traveled over 60
miles
he's on the hunt
not for food instead the girl of his
dreams
she's close he can smell her scent
by the morning he finally spots his fair
furred Maiden
but a rival suitors already staked his
claim
time for this team to turn around
and fight
this may be his only chance to mate this
year
on two legs the rivals use size to
intimidate
but neither backs down
Rises as tall as a basketball hoop
push comes to show both bears are
matched for strength and size
so if the sweet teen wants to win the
girl he'll have to do some serious
damage their necks are longer than other
Bears it's an easy target lying inches
from the surface the Rival has muscles
crucial for swimming and hunting when
you take out the neck you take out the
bear
this time the Rival Dodges the attack
such quickfire combat is taxing for
these bulky animals
on the floor the novice teen fighter is
tiring
polar bears drain energy twice as quick
as other animals
and covers they both land solid fights
on each other's necks
their hooked canines are the length of
human thumbs and can slash through thick
flesh
huge jaw muscles give a bite force the
equivalent of being crushed by a grand
piano
finally our teenage bear seizes his
moment
he delivers a damaging fight
his rival backs away
further injury could mean he'll never
hunt or swim again
the young Victor wins the heart of his
princess
but it's a whirlwind Romance
he'll spend only a week with her before
he's off to do it all again
[Music]
from the Frozen ice shelves of the
Arctic
to the sizzling coasts of Indonesia
home turf to the gnarliest fighters at
Animal Fight Night
[Music]
Komodo dragons
weighing in at nearly twice the weight
of your kitchen fridge
they're the biggest lizards in the world
a deadly combination of lethal weapons
and toxic saliva is key to their killing
prowess
just a single venomous bite is enough to
take down prey four times their size
killing them from the inside out
[Music]
komodo's may be solitary Hunters but
they're communal eaters
the dinner table is the perfect place to
pick a fight and establish whose boss in
this Komodo Kingdom
[Music]
here on Komodo Island this head honcho
Reigns Supreme he lives a dragon's dream
he gets the most girls the most food and
the most respect on these coasts to
mount a serious title challenge younger
komodos must be in their fighting crime
confront the honcho when you're not
and you'll be savagely eaten up
one tenth of his diet is smaller weaker
komodo's
for today's Young Challenger has bited
his time
he now weighs in pound per pound with
the Honcho
the Komodo kid
is ready to tip the hierarchy upside
down
the fight is on
urge to get pinned down
loses
the kids got some great technique he
slams his opponent to the ground with a
well-executed SmackDown
[Music]
but the head honcho knows how to hit
back even harder
he'll fight dirty and he's well equipped
for the job
like the tips of steak knives each of
his 60 teeth are dangerously curved and
serrated
they're also entirely disposable
komodo's replace up to 200 teeth a year
luckily for the kid komodos are immune
to their own venomous bites
but it doesn't mean they don't hurt
fighting through the pain he takes a
last-ditch swipe at the honcho but his
claws make no mark on scales which are
reinforced with dense bone
the kids no match for his fearsome rival
[Music]
too bloody to continue
he submits to the PIN
[Music]
head honcho shown why he's the boss
around here
Komodo Island
never punch above your weight
when winter comes our next contenders
have no problem reaching a required
weight
thousands of elephant seals take over
beaches across the world
every plot of Oceanside property is
controlled by a beach master and his
Harrow of up to 200 females
larger and heavier than an average
American car
Masters are formidable Fighters
and they have to be
twice an hour every day young males
challenge the beach Master for control
of his females
males hear don't eat or drink for over
four months
just Relentless fighting for a chance to
mate
but 99 of bulls will fail to pass on
their genes
leaving a lot of lonely Bachelors to
sunbathe solo
here on the shores of South Georgia
on the right accepts a challenge from
arrival
but an impatient young punk Cuts in
determined to seize control of the Harem
right here right now
each Master into the surf
wow it's his big chance to take the
beach and take the girls
all right
their bodies are prepped for battle
in times more testosterone than normal
is pumping through their blood
the punk delivers the opening hit
in elephant seal bouts tactics are
simple slam down teeth first and cause
maximum damage quicker than your
opponent
in fights like these sixty percent of
alpha Bulls lose control of their Harem
every winter
but it's not just females that are at
stake
necks can be hacked open and faces torn
to shreds the loser may not return to
shore alive
the beach Master sinks four massive
canines into his rival
growing up to six inches long his teeth
are like daggers
easily drawing blood from his opponent
heavyweights are feeling the strain
but elephant seals fight to total
exhaustion
Blow from the beach Master forces a
timeout
seconds later the young punk drags the
old champ back into the ring
the bloody Beach Master tries to slice
his opponent's neck
but it doesn't phase the young punk
exhausted the old champ is now in
serious trouble
[Music]
this young elephant seal is taking on an
old beach Master for this season's
mating rights
the beach Master is planning but he's a
tough battle-hardened Warrior
nearly as thick as brick wall his
blubber acts as a home-grown shield
and thick scar tissue from previous
fights provide a further layer of
leathery armor a reminder to his
opponent that he's no amateur
this Wise Old Beach Master knows that
attack
the best form of Defense
out of nowhere he digs deep and
unleashes a fight-ending SmackDown
the punk has been pulverized he won't be
Beach Master this season
his wounds are so severe they're
unlikely to ever heal
he may not last the winter
which Master retains his title as
reigning champion of the South Georgia
beaches
with a deafening Roar of Victory the old
champ humiliates his opponent one last
time
some Coastal creatures go to Great
Lengths to find love
but none as Extreme as the mudskipper
these strange looking fish leave the
watery Comforts of the ocean and brave a
brand new dry world
all to find a mate on the mud flats
this little Skipper is a slimy bundle of
nerves it's his first time on the dating
scene
he may be small but for Skippers sizes
and everything
a girl really wants a guy with a perfect
home on Prime real estate
a burrow close to the tide
built in soft mud
it's somewhere to raise a family keep
cool and hide from predators
the novice daters got the perfect patch
so surely you'll find the perfect match
finally a little skip to lure the ladies
in
so fast
the Big Daddy of these mud flats is
watching
no first-timer is going to build a
Swanky love bunker on his patch
oh
so he dares the little novice to about
for the burrow
[Music]
the novice please
but the big daddy gives him no choice
but to fight
first they flaunt their fangs it's a
display of intimidation
mud skippers have spine-like teeth
embedded into their skull
they're tiny but for a rival mud skipper
they're terrifying they're both too
mouthy to back down
the big daddy chances a few cheap bites
but the novice has built-in protection
the skin on his head and upper body are
extra thick and resistant to puncture
using two special types of thin these
weird fish can skip about on land with
ease their pelvic fin is stiff and
strong used to Jack themselves up off
the ground and their front fins have
makeshift elbows allowing them to propel
themselves across the mud great when
you're on the attack but they also have
an acrobatic way of escaping Rivals they
curl up tight and slap their tail hard
against the mud
catapulting themselves to feed into the
air and out of the way
you can skip but you can't hide it all
gets too much for the little novice time
to get out of here pronto
there's always next year
or maybe not
[Music]
high in the Malaysian Skies
this pair of sea eagles Reigns over
their empire
an area the size of Paris
this prime location has served them well
for over a decade
here they raise their young
and capitalize on Rich hunting grounds
nearly seven feet but weighing barely
seven pounds a wedged tail for steering
and balance an eight needle-pointed
Talons for piercing flesh praise stand
no chance
sea eagles are designed for the hunt but
they're also perfectly engineered for
air-to-air battle
and life team are under attack
a Maverick Intruder wants to conquer
their precious Dominion
starts to ransack the family's feeding
grounds
war is declared
[Music]
this pair of sea eagles are at War but
traditional roles are reversed
females can be up to 50 percent larger
than males so Dad stays on the home
front
while Mom earns her stripes in an aerial
dog fight to the death
the young mom and Intruder Clash midair
Talent Talon they plummet toward Earth
as they spin through the skies
it's a combat style called whirling and
it only ends when the contenders hit the
ground dead or alive
but the mom loses her nerve and lets go
she has to up her game if she wants to
defend herself and her family
her broad Wings provide huge amounts of
lift as she climbs High into the skies
tries to gain the height advantage over
her rival
follow suit
[Music]
a race to the heavens
the mother goes in for the attack
[Music]
their talons lock in battle
mountains in their feet form a ratchet
mechanism creating an immense grip which
can be held for hours
something plain muscles just can't do
[Music]
let go and lose
who dares wins
[Music]
he'll spend up to 5 000 degrees as they
continue to lose altitude fast
[Music]
dad and kids can only look on fearing
the worst for Mom she could be mangled
and dying on the jungle floor
suddenly she emerges
unharmed
her Empire and her family are safe once
again
[Music]
foreign
to super heavy weights in the water
walruses rule in a weight class of Their
Own
they dive over 300 feet deep into the
Frozen Seas
withstand temperatures plummeting to as
low as minus 30 degrees
and they're tooled up to the teeth
their tusks grow longer than baseball
bats
and made of solid Ivory they can slice
through eight inches of ice
they look tough and fight rough
when the ice flows melt females migrate
North to nurse their young for the males
it's time to haul out and relax at the
Arctic sunshine
here at Bristol Bay in Alaska the
resident Beach Bums enjoy peace in
perfect conditions
foreign
but there's trouble in these Waters
a herd of latecomers one in on the beach
party
they've already spent two-thirds of the
year at sea
with nowhere else to go hauling out has
become a matter of life and death
but this Rock Beach is full to the grill
if the latecomers want to patch a peach
they'll need to oust the resident
bathers
so they start to psych out their rivals
on plan throwing their gigantic tusks
into the air the beach bums stand their
ground they can't risk losing their
residence for the summer
now it's a battle on the beach
Invaders make a beeline for the back of
the beach
where there's smooth Rock great sun and
most importantly protection from
predators
but they're stopped in their tracks
the resident Beach Bum struggled to keep
the determined Invaders at Bed
the late comers jab and stab their way
to the back of the beach
the biggest Invaders with the longest
tusks win the prized spots
[Music]
this huge latecomer has battled through
to a prime position While others count
the costs
as for the losers they'll have to bully
their way on to another beach before
Summer's over
[Music]
here on the Galapagos Islands
Naz Kabuki
Boop animal fight night to its most
primal
but it's the newborn chicks who have to
fight the hardest to survive
all kids squabble for Mom's attention
but it's more than just affection that
rides on this fight
mom can only feed one of her children
and it's down to the kids to Duke it out
and decide who gets fed
[Music]
this first-born booby chick awaits the
arrival of his brother
a sworn enemy born straight into the
wrestling ring
the brothers are only a few days old
when they begin the fight of their life
the odds quickly stack up against the
little brother
the weight Advantage is with his older
sibling
[Music]
as they start to wrestle Their little
bodies react On Cue
at normally high levels of testosterone
are produced making them extra
aggressive for the contest to come
[Music]
the younger chick produces a third more
than his older brother
he stands a Fighting Chance
can afford to get jostled out of the
ring
their lives depend on it
get shoved out and mom won't pull you
back in
the little brother stays defiant and
stumbles back to the nest
only to be met with a second round
a few nips to the neck are enough to
weaken his brother
once again the little one is muscled out
despite his desperate pleas
too weak to fight back again
it's game over
the winner
all the love in the world
this Victory may be a selfish one but
this is what it takes to survive Animal
Fight Night
the waves of the Pacific Ocean
live blenny fish
the resident cuties of the ocean floor
dainty mild-mannered and timid
but meet the black sheep of the family
[Music]
the sarcastic Fringe head
they are not
[Music]
they open their jaws wide to Bear an
arsenal of thorn-like teeth
which aren't for empty threats
this old crank may be the size of a
human forearm
but he knows how to pack a punch
you'll take on anything that swims onto
his property whatever shape or size
so what happens when an equally grouchy
Fringe head moves in next door
turf war on the ocean floor
the old crank starts his eviction
campaign using some Brute Force
but the pesky neighbor won't give up his
home that is
[Music]
so the crank turns to bully tactics
the neighbor finally cracks
he's not going to stand for such low
life Behavior
The Fringe heads go cheap to cheek in
the world's most ferocious makeout
session
but there's no kissing here
they interlock teeth as they shove each
other over and over again
ultimate contest of aggression and
Authority
but then the old crank bites
the neighbor returns fire
sinking his teeth into his rival even
harder
this spring
after a dog in 20 minutes there's still
no sign of resolution
being neighbors might be way too close
for comfort
but it looks like they'll just have to
grin and bear it
[Music]
thank you down under fight night has a
contender that's amped up
and angry
all day
every day
Tasmanian devils live a life of hellish
greed and aggression
even kangaroos over three times their
size steer clear
competition among Devils is fierce
three quarters of the young never make
it to adulthood
because they're never more than a meal
away from a life-threatening fight
[Applause]
oh
the coastal forests of Tasmania
it's every devil for himself
this morning
there's fresh meat in the air
this hungry devil can smell it
there's no time to waste
Tasmanian devils have a near insatiable
appetite
others have gotten to the meat first
so he muzzles his way in
he can devour 40 of his body weight in
just half an hour
that's the equivalent of a man eating an
80 pound steak in one sitting
but sharing with your enemies isn't so
simple
the hungry latecomer tries to steal a
fight from arrival
this won't be tolerated
[Music]
a lunch dispute is quickly escalating
up on their hind legs two Tasmanian
devils test each other's strength and
tenacity it's a fighting method called
jaw wrestling
the hungry devil knows he's in trouble
and his rival
[Applause]
[Music]
he turns on his heels and makes a run
for it
but his adversary is in Hot Pursuit
for the Rival it's the perfect chance to
eliminate future competition now
[Applause]
vicious bites
bite straight to the face
their huge heads are packed with muscles
and count a quarter of their entire
weight
pound for pound Devils have the most
powerful bite in the world and their
skulls are made of sponge-like bone
designed to absorb the sheer shock of
such heavy-duty biting
[Applause]
the Rival has the hungry Devil in a
vice-like grip
just where he wants it
[Applause]
pins his opponent to the ground and goes
in for a final strike
[Applause]
hungry devil snatches a lucky escape and
runs for his life
he won't be coming back around here
anytime soon
and next time he'll wait in line for his
lunch
in the dark Waters of the Mexican Coast
strange creatures take food fights to a
whole new level
a cartel of Humboldt squid are on the
hunt for a midnight snack
Humboldt's live for only a single year
growing from a tiny egg to the size of a
man
to fuel this insane growth they eat
almost anything
including each other
tonight this Humboldt has one of his own
on the menu
the chase is on
you can hit speeds up to 15 miles per
hour using a perfectly tuned Turbo
System
he draws water into his body then
violently spits it back out
thrusting him through the water Like a
Torpedo
cannibal uses his Frontline weapons
eight elastic arms and two lightning
quick tentacles
it only takes 20 milliseconds to land a
deadly strike
he plants 2 000 suction cups on his
victim
come armed with 36 Barbed hooks piercing
flesh and locking on with a vice-like
grip
[Music]
but at the center the most formidable
weapon a razor-sharp beak
[Music]
made from one of the hardest and
stiffest materials found in nature it
can rip through Kevlar and steel
but tonight's dinner won't go down
without a fight
he blasts his frenzied attacker with a
torrent of toxic ink
it contains enzymes designed to throw
the enemy completely off his senses
it works for now
clouded and Confused the crazed cannibal
let's go
but he finds his bearings and locks on
again forcing his victim into a spin
[Music]
resistance is futile
the crazed cannibal drags the victim
away to a quiet corner of the ocean
now
it's just a well-earned move
Penguins The Lovable Little Rascals of
the animal world
17 species big and small
covering coasts across the southern
hemisphere
[Music]
they may look friendly
but when Fight Night arrives
the gloves are off
when you live in colonies that can
number into the Millions
keeping your cool Ain't Easy
it's not uncommon for 40 Penguins to
squeeze into an area the size of a ping
pong table
so if you want personal space you gotta
fight for it
[Music]
Antarctica's adeli Penguins
these highly protective parents will go
to the ends of the ice for their own
chicks but it's an entirely different
story when placed with the Yahoo of
others
this chick lost and looking for warmth
in the nearby Nest is told to stay away
certain terms
alone and unable to feed himself he
won't survive long if he doesn't find
his mom soon
[Music]
she makes the mistake of trampling
through another's Nest
being flightless penguins use their flat
bony flippers for two things only
swimming and slapping
the fighting frenzy crashes into another
parrot's Nest creating even more Havoc
[Music]
Penguins dragged their Rivals into
slapping Distance by pecking at their
head and yanking them in closer
but this mom can't be starting any more
fights
he's got a chick to retrieve before it's
too late
she arrives in the nick of time and
fights off her chick's bullies once and
for all
finally safe and sound he won't be
leaving Mom's side anytime soon
[Music]
here among the Galapagos volcanoes a
fighter that never relies on violence to
settle its scores
well
almost never
marine iguanas live a tranquil life in
the Crystal Blue Waters of the Pacific
[Music]
but come mating season in January the
harmony quickly dissolves
[Music]
they come ashore to shotgun territories
to have a crib on the lava crust is to
have any chance of attracting a mate
boundary disputes become an everyday
hazard
fight these cold-blooded contenders must
first raise their heartbeats by warming
up in the Sun
and when they start to head back
fired up
built they're armed with a full head of
horns and sharp fork-like teeth they
could easily do some serious damage
but opening a can of whoop ass just
isn't their style these vegetarians
don't pay for blood they settle their
scores with their heads quite literally
here on bartolome island it's crunch
time for these two iguanas
on our right a hot shot male desperately
trying to defend his digs on the lava
rock
on the left a ballsy Challenger defying
to steal the hot property
first to get shoved into the sea loses
thank you made of the same material as
bison's horns and iguana's head scales
are the toughest part of the body
perfect when ramming your way to Victory
marine iguanas get a grip
their claws sharper stronger and longer
than those of other iguanas are
specially designed to cling onto wet
slippery rock
they both stopped
marine iguanas may have the will to
fight but they don't have the stem they
can only fight for a few minutes before
needing a rest
without warning the ballsy Challenger
swings his head and throws his rival off
balance
the Hot Shot hits the waves
his tendency on the Rocks is up
[Applause]
Victorious The Invader trials his new
position of dominance with another round
of head banging
but there's no reply
the crib on the coast is now his to lose
across the Pacific Ocean is a predator
that has no qualms about killing
sand tiger sharks
slaying is second nature
because they're born ruthless killers
still in the womb this four-week-old pup
is barely five inches long
but he already has the tools to kill
and he doesn't even wait until he's born
to use them
because once the food in his yolk sack
Runs Dry
he must find a new source of nutrition
so he turns on his own brothers and
sisters
every pup for itself
[Music]
as the oldest he has the most developed
weapons
so the younger siblings have little
chance
[Music]
still in their yolk sacks
even less
[Music]
kill then eat
standard protocol for sharks
no matter how old
biologists have captured footage of this
big brother feeding on his kills
and he's not finished there
[Music]
he moves on to Mom's Relentless supply
of unfertilized eggs
you'll eat 170 of them a day this will
go on for another 11 months when he'll
be Unleashed into the Seas a genuine
Natural Born Killer
[Music]
thank you